hey guys it is the 20th of October today
my name is just and you're watching
games but nice [ __ ] army packed up
about that whole kajima allegedly
leaving the company thing which came off
yesterday and according to them the game
definitely on vacations Konami told the
Japanese publication Tokyo sports that
Kajima is still a company employee
explaining currently Kojima and the
development team are finished developing
Metal Gear Solid fights and are taking a
long time off from work because the
development time for console games is so
long and fatigue builds up it's common
for employees to take extended periods
of time off when development is finished
Konami also said they have no knowledge
of the so-called leaving ceremony rajma
which reportedly occurred on october
nine according to a New Yorker article
subsequently journalist Simon Parkin who
wrote The New Yorker piece tweeted a
photo of the farewell party that took
place in response to konami exclaims
next up for something you definitely
need in your life best buy a selling
vault boy socks with their gold edition
of fallout 4 yes it seems the developers
have completely run out of ideas for
what to pack in with special editions
and socks is where we've landed the $85
bundle which is exclusive to best buy is
available for xbox one or ps4 and
includes the game the DLC season pass
and the socks given that the base game
already cost 60 bucks and the DLC pass
will be 30 you may as well pick up this
one and get the free stock if you were
intending to grab yourself the DLC path
anyway finally kotaku has discovered
through multiple sources that the story
changes which were made to destiny a
year before its release did indeed
happen and they were against the writers
wishes Destiny's story has become an
infamous point of contention in
September court documents reveal that
the narrative had been rebooted entirely
just a year before it came out which may
explain why so much of it was shifted
out of the game and onto the companion
according to kotaku sources bunchy
decided that shows statins original
story was too campy and linear so they
quote scrapped plot threads overhauled
characters and rewrote most of the
dialogue start and left Bungie in 2013
and now works as a senior creative
director at Microsoft allegedly while
much of his original destiny story was
overhauled Bungie cats funky elements
including the traveller the concept of
guardians and enemy types like the Cabal
and vex let me know down in that comment
section what your theories are on the
whole Kaname and kaja Masaga you can add
a game spot where we've got info on a
ps4 firmware update and a new destiny
patch that is everything I have for you
today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I will catch you
tomorrow